all right i'm i'm going to have to sort
of issue an apology here uh we have a
voicemail number that number is 219
to david p uh i am causing huge
problems for one of our viewers
uh with his fiancee take a listen to
this
hey david my name is danny this is the
first time i'm calling in
but i've been a listener for a few years
now and
i was really just calling to ask kindly
for you to dial
back on the reasonable and wise takes
right it's starting to cause some
jealousy issues with my fiance
that i listen to you uh so often so
sorry um and not only
politics but um also your assessment of
pies and apple pies
especially right um i think the only
major disagreement i've had lately has
been
with your take on sweet potatoes is
quote the perfect
vegetable um in fact i submit to you
that in fact
bell peppers are the perfect special oh
my god
clean them out you can eat them like an
apple they taste great they're not
annoyingly spicy they're crispy you can
stuff them and bake them oh dear anyways
i just need for you to dial back on the
stellar opinion pieces
you're handing out media literacy like
it's candy on halloween
um and uh you're also the biggest reason
i voted i was
i'm a burning supporter but that's
important biden thanks to you so um
for the sake of my happily ever after
would you please just cut it out
yeah listen um i i apologize that your
fiance is getting jealous
and and all of that um but so here
a bell pepper is the is better than a
sweet potato and
i i'm not anti-bell pepper in any way
but i but when you're cooking you dip
you dip a bell pepper in some hummus
that's great but
in cooking a jalapeno okay you're adding
a little heat but a
bell pepper is not dramatically
different than an onion in that it gets
soft and absorbs the flavor of whatever
is there
sweet potato brings so much more to the
table from the standpoint of flavor
from the standpoint of nutrition from
the standpoint of of caloric density
and i just read a fascinating i i have
loved sweet potatoes since i was a
little kid
when i was first sampling baby food
uh back in 1984 i guess 85.
you know 84. it would have been um when
i first got my first taste of sweet
potato
um my eyes lit up it was an it was an
incredible day
and you know a lot of people think
because a sweet potato has the word
potato in it that it's
it's like a potato it has nothing to do
with a potato understand that potatoes
are the stems
of a plant whereas sweet potatoes are
the root
or some say the root i say root um
the uh it's a totally different family
it is uh a potato and a sweet potato
could not be more different and by the
way
all these people in the u.s who
interchangeably talk about a sweet
potato and a yam
uh i don't know that i've ever seen a
yam an actual yam in the united states
yams are gigantic compared to sweet
potatoes they look different
let's stop miss naming sweet potatoes as
yams anyway i could go on for probably
an hour about sweet potatoes
but the the the mere idea that a bell
pepper is going to hold a candle to
sweet potatoes i find that offensive but
otherwise i love the praise i love that
this caller voted thanks to the show etc
etc
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we'll talk about rudy giuliani's
slippery cell phone
we will talk about the vatican's
position on vaccines for the virus
that use abortion cell lines hint
they're okay with it
and deborah burks is going bye-bye when
joe biden
transitions in because she's retiring
and we'll talk about what we think is
behind that
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com and get
instant access to the bonus show